One of the producers of our radio program, Sean Cole, used to live in Toronto. And he went out to bars a lot when he was there. And at one point, he heard this rumor about the places that he was hanging out.
我们电台节目的制作人之一，肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole），过去住在多伦多。他在那里时经常去酒吧。有一次，他听到了关于他常去的那几家店的传闻。
A friend of mine basically said, the thing about these bars-- he actually said, the gasoline that allows them to function was cocaine.
我的一个朋友基本上是说，关于这些酒吧的事情——他其实是说，维持它们运作的汽油就是可卡因。
Meaning the staff was doing cocaine?
意思是员工在吸可卡因吗？
The bartenders were on coke. And I was like, how did I not notice? You know?
酒保在吸可卡因。我当时就想，我怎么没发现呢？你知道吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
And I wondered how true that was.
我很好奇这到底有多真实。
Did you do any coke tonight?
你今晚吸可卡因了吗？
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
吸了。[笑声]
How much?
多少？
Just a bump.
就一点点。
So that's like, what is that.
那大概是，那是什么。
That's like the tip of a key.
就像钥匙尖那么多。
So this is one of about a dozen bartenders that I interviewed, all anonymously.
所以这是我采访过的十几位酒保之一，全是匿名采访。
When she says a key, she means like--
当她说钥匙时，她的意思是——
Like a house key. You sniff it off of that.
就像房门钥匙。你就从那上面吸。
But I have done it while I'm working. But I don't do it until later, like past 1:00.
但我确实在工作时吸过。但我不会在很早的时候吸，通常是在一点之后。
Oh, I see.
哦，我明白了。
Yes.
是的。
And how often does that happen?
那种情况发生的频率是多少？
Umm, like, every weekend.
嗯，大概，每个周末吧。
I had this experience years ago. A friend sat me down and told me that she'd just started going to AA. And she wanted me to know that she knew how annoying it must have been for me and all of our friends at the time that she was always on coke back when we first were getting to know each other.
多年前我有过这样的经历。一个朋友让我坐下来，告诉我她刚开始去参加戒酒互助会（AA）。她想让我知道，她明白当初我们在刚认识时，她总是处于可卡因的高峰状态，这对我和我们的所有朋友来说一定很烦人。
She was running to the bathroom all the time. She was really hyper. And I told her, I had no idea. I told her, I just assumed that's your personality. You're a little manic, small bladder. And of course, right?
她老是往洗手间跑。她非常亢奋。我告诉她，我根本不知道。我告诉她，我只是以为那是你的性格。你有点躁狂，膀胱还小。当然了，对吧？
I think, if you're not a daily drug user, you're not a big drug user, it doesn't occur to you that the people around you might be high. And Sean found that this bar scene he thought he knew so well did, actually, seem to be run on cocaine.
我想，如果你不是每天都吸毒的人，不是重度吸毒者，你根本不会想到周围的人可能在吸毒。肖恩发现，他以为自己很了解的那个酒吧圈子，实际上确实似乎是靠可卡因运作的。
So lots of bars in certain areas of town, definitely, coke is like fuel for the staff. Partly because, you know, these bars, it's like drinking on the job is kind of expected.
所以城里某些地区的许多酒吧，毫无疑问，可卡因就像员工的燃料。部分原因是，你知道，这些酒吧，在工作中喝酒被视为理所当然。
People are buying me shots. And I see people I know, and I'm buying them shots. And then, just, you start to get the spins.
人们给我买酒喝。我见到认识的人，我也给他们买酒。然后，你就开始头晕了。
It's like, after you do four or five shots, I'm like, OK. I don't want to be too drunk. I need something to straighten me up.
就像，喝了四五杯之后，我就想，好吧。我不想喝得太醉。我需要点东西让我清醒一下。
Jeez, I really want a line right now to straighten this up.
天哪，我现在真想来一条线让自己清醒一下。
That's the phrase you keep hearing.
这就是你一直听到的短语。
Everyone uses it so loosely. It's straightening out. You need to straighten out.
每个人都用得很随意。这是在理顺。你需要理顺一下。
Yeah, you just take a quick little jump down to the bathroom, straighten yourself up. Come upstairs.
是啊，你只要快速跑到洗手间，理顺一下自己。然后上来。
How often does that happen to you?
这种情况你发生的频率是多少？
Uh, eight minutes ago.
呃，八分钟前。
OK.
好的。
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑声] 是啊。
So their bosses have to know, right?
所以他们的老板肯定知道，对吧？
The bosses are doing it too sometimes.
老板有时候也在吸。
For the first little while, the bar I worked at, the managers were doing lines of cocaine in order to sober up enough so they could cash out the bartenders, who were completely inebriated. Oh! I also knew policemen who were partaking.
在最初的一段时间里，我工作的酒吧，经理们会吸可卡因，为了能清醒到足以给那些已经完全醉倒的酒保结账。哦！我还认识一些也参与其中的警察。
In cocaine?
吸可卡因吗？
In the bathroom, with the manager, in uniform. It blew me away! I was so naive. I was like, what? It would be like finding out Superman is-- you know--
在洗手间里，和经理一起，穿着制服。这让我震惊！我真是太天真了。我当时想，什么？这就像发现超人是——你知道——
Doing cocaine.
在吸可卡因。
--doing cocaine! Exactly.
——在吸可卡因！没错。
Of course, to put it in perspective, this is a cop doing cocaine in a city whose mayor was caught on video smoking crack and stayed in his job. He's finally going to rehab now. And all of this got us thinking here at the radio show, how many people around us are high right now? Like, right this second?
当然，从长远来看，这可是一名警察在吸可卡因，而这座城市的市长被拍到吸快克毒品视频后却还保住了他的工作。他现在终于要去做康复治疗了。所有这些让我们电台节目组开始思考，我们周围有多少人现在正处于“嗨”的状态？就像，就在这一秒？
OK, if you're out in the world right now as you're hearing me say these words, look around at the people around you. Look at their faces. Could one of them be high? And I mean, everywhere you go, right? It's like, for example, we found this book that came out a couple of years ago by a guy named Ethan Bryson.
好了，如果你现在正在听我说这些话，看看你周围的人。看看他们的脸。其中一个人可能正在“嗨”吗？我的意思是，你去任何地方都是这样，对吧？比如，我们发现了这本几年前出的书，作者叫伊森·布莱森（Ethan Bryson）。
So the title of the book is Addicted Healers. And the subtitle is "5 Key Signs Your Healthcare Professional May Be Drug Impaired."
书名是《成瘾的治疗者》。副标题是“你的医疗专业人员可能受药物影响的5个关键迹象”。
And right here on page xviii, it says, "Rates of illicit drug use by health care professionals within the past year ranged from 8% to 20%, depending on the type of personnel within the health care industry." And then, it says, "At any given time, roughly 3% to 5% of this population is using illicit drugs while they are caring for patients."
就在第十八页，上面写着：“过去一年中，医疗专业人员非法使用药物的比例在8%到20%之间，取决于医疗行业内人员的类型。”然后，它说：“在任何特定时间，大约有3%到5%的人群在照顾病人时使用非法药物。”
3% to 5%, you mean of all health care professionals?
3%到5%，你是说所有的医疗专业人员？
All across the profession.
整个职业范围内。
Wow, which drugs?
哇，哪些药物？
They all have their drug of choice. And we actually played this kind of word association game.
他们都有自己偏好的药物。我们其实玩过这种词汇联想游戏。
Physicians?
医师？
Pills, Oxycontin, oxycodone.
药片，奥施康定，羟考酮。
Nurses.
护士。
Intravenous opioid-based drugs.
静脉注射阿片类药物。
Psychiatrists.
精神科医生。
Benzodiazepines.
苯二氮卓类药物。
Anesthesiologists.
麻醉师。
Fentanyl.
芬太尼。
You said that so fast!
你说的太快了！
That is the biggest drug.
那是最大的毒品。
I should point out here that Dr. Bryson is himself an anesthesiologist.
我应该指出，布莱森医生本人就是一名麻醉师。
Say it again, fentanyl?
再说一遍，芬太尼？
Fentanyl. It's a highly potent derivative of morphine.
芬太尼。它是吗啡的一种强效衍生物。
It's actually like 80 times more potent than morphine and can significantly mess with your judgment. It's extremely addictive. And Dr. Bryson pointed out that most medical professionals don't have to take drug tests. Military personnel, on the other hand, do.
它实际上比吗啡强80倍左右，会严重影响你的判断力。它极易让人上瘾。布莱森医生指出，大多数医疗专业人员不需要接受药物测试。而另一方面，军事人员则需要。
Now, many of you reported last week on the investigation involving some of our airmen and illegal drug possession.
现在，你们中许多人上周报道了涉及我们部分空军人员非法持有毒品的调查。
This is the Secretary of the Air Force, Deborah Lee James, giving a press conference a few months ago. Basically, two lieutenants were busted for allegedly dealing amphetamines and ecstasy. And they were found out, because they were sending text messages to other airmen about drugs.
这是空军部长黛博拉·李·詹姆斯（Deborah Lee James）几个月前举行的新闻发布会。基本上，两名中尉因涉嫌贩卖安非他命和摇头丸而被捕。他们被发现是因为他们给其他空军人员发了关于毒品的短信。
Well, it turns out that three of the 10 who were implicated in this drug investigation were from our Air Force Global Strike Command, which is the command where our ICBM missile forces reside.
好吧，事实证明，在这次毒品调查中受牵连的10人中，有3人来自我们的空军全球打击司令部，也就是我们的洲际弹道导弹部队驻扎的司令部。
ICBM, that is--
洲际弹道导弹，那是——
The nuclear warheads.
核弹头。
Well, that doesn't seem like somebody we want high.
嗯，那看起来可不是我们想让其处于“嗨”状态的人。
Not someone we want high.
不是我们想让其处于“嗨”状态的人。
Sean, are there surveys measuring how many of us are high all the time?
肖恩，有没有调查测量我们中有多少人是一直处于“嗨”状态的？
I mean-- [SIGH] There's not a lot of data. There's workplace drug tests that show 3 and 1/2% of workers test positive for drugs. But obviously, that's only in workplaces that test for drugs in the first place.
我的意思是——[叹气] 没有多少数据。职场药物测试显示3.5%的工人药物检测呈阳性。但显然，那只针对那些首先进行药物测试的职场。
One of the experts on this data, who's wonderfully named, Dr. Barry Sample from Quest Diagnostics told me drug use is a couple percentage points higher in places that don't test for drugs.
该数据的专家之一，名字非常好的巴里·桑普尔（Barry Sample）博士来自Quest Diagnostics，他告诉我，在那些不进行药物测试的地方，药物使用率要高出几个百分点。
Which jobs have the highest drug use?
哪些工作药物使用率最高？
So, the Department of Health and Human Services actually has numbers on that. The latest ones that I found said-- so this is people who say, yes, I've done illicit drugs in the past month. People who work in real estate is about 7%. Same for mining.
所以，美国卫生与公众服务部实际上有相关数据。我找到的最新数据说——这些是说，是的，我在过去一个月里使用过非法药物的人。从事房地产行业的人大约占7%。矿业也是一样。
Mining? 7%.
矿业？7%。
Mining. Retail is 9 and 1/2%. Construction workers is about 14%. So that means roughly one in seven construction workers. The highest is accommodation and food services.
矿业。零售业是9.5%。建筑工人大约是14%。这意味着大约七分之一的建筑工人。最高的是住宿和餐饮服务业。
That would include, dare I say, bartenders? [LAUGHS]
那会包括，我敢说，酒保吗？[笑声]
Yes. Accommodation and food services, roughly one in six admit on the survey to using drugs.
是的。住宿和餐饮服务业，大约六分之一的人在调查中承认使用药物。
It could be higher, though, right?
那可能更高，对吧？
It could be higher? What do you mean?
可能更高？你是什么意思？
It could be higher than one of six actually do drugs.
可能比六分之一的人实际使用药物的比例更高。
Oh, it could be higher--
哦，可能更高——
Right, one out of six--
对，六分之一——
--meaning one out of six admit on the survey--
——意思是六分之一的人在调查中承认——
--admit on the survey to drug use. Some more of them, actually, might be doing it.
——在调查中承认使用药物。他们中可能有更多人实际上在这么做。
Yeah, maybe.
是啊，也许吧。
They should try the survey in Toronto.
他们应该在多伦多试试这个调查。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Well, today on our radio program, the secret world of getting high, which is, OK, maybe not such a well-kept secret. It is all around us all the time. High people mingling with us, working, passing, laughing extra hard at our jokes. We don't even know why.
好了，今天我们的电台节目，关于“嗨”的秘密世界，也就是，好吧，也许不是什么保密的秘密。它一直都在我们身边。处于“嗨”状态的人与我们混在一起，工作，经过，对我们的笑话笑得特别大声。我们甚至不知道为什么。
We have stories today of great drug experiences, and awful drug experiences, and funny drug experiences; tales of miscalculation, bad judgment, and dumb-assery. We have comedians Marc Maron and Wyatt Cenac. From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
今天我们有关于伟大的药物体验、糟糕的药物体验和有趣的药物体验的故事；关于误判、判断失误和愚蠢行为的传说。我们有喜剧演员马克·马龙（Marc Maron）和怀亚特·塞纳克（Wyatt Cenac）。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。请继续收听。
Act One, High on the Corporate Ladder. So there's this secret society, many million strong, people who are going through life high. Maybe you are part of this society. If not, you're probably dealing regularly with people who are, cashiers, baristas, and stockbrokers, and cab drivers, maybe the cop writing that parking ticket. Alex Blumberg has this story about just how hard it is to tell who is in that society and who isn't.
第一幕，职场高处。所以有一个庞大的秘密社团，有几百万人，人们在“嗨”的状态下过着生活。也许你就是这个社团的一员。如果不是，你可能经常在和那些处于“嗨”状态的人打交道，收银员、咖啡师、股票经纪人和出租车司机，也许还有给你开停车罚单的警察。亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）讲述了这个关于分辨谁在这个社团里谁不在有多难的故事。
Richard, for many years, was a member of that society, the society of people who get high at work.
理查德，多年来，一直是那个社团的一员，即在工作中“嗨”起来的人组成的社团。
I would roll a thin joint and start smoking in the morning. I'd usually duck down at one of the back stairways and take a few more tokes during the day. I'd smoke at lunch. I'd smoke a little bit in the afternoon. I would basically stay high all day long.
我会卷一根细细的烟卷，早上就开始抽。我通常会溜进后楼梯，白天再抽几口。我在午餐时抽。我下午会抽一点。我基本上整天都处于“嗨”的状态。
And what exactly was your job title?
你的具体职位是什么？
I was chief operating [LAUGHS] officer of the second largest ad agency in town. [LAUGHS]
我是城里第二大广告公司的首席运营[笑声]官。[笑声]
[LAUGHS] How many people at your company knew that you were doing this?
[笑声] 你们公司有多少人知道你在做这件事？
Um, somewhere between three and all of them.
嗯，三个人到所有人之间吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Richard says that, at the time, he thought he was hiding his habit. But in retrospect, who knows? One of the head executives toking up in the stairwell every day, how could he hide that? On the other hand, there's this. I had no idea that this was going  on. And I'm Richard's son.
理查德说，当时他以为自己隐藏了习惯。但回顾过去，谁知道呢？作为每天在楼梯间抽烟的高管之一，他怎么可能隐藏得住？另一方面，还有这个。我完全不知道发生了什么。而我是理查德的儿子。
I only found out that my dad was getting high at work every day long after the fact, when I was in my 30s. And I found out because my dad got cancer. It was a horrible week. It started with the discovery that the pain in my dad's back wasn't just a pinched nerve. And it ended with a diagnosis of lymphoma, a particular form of lymphoma that we had learned that week to root for, because it's actually curable. That's the word they used. Back then, I didn't even know you could say that about cancer.
直到很久以后，当我30多岁时，我才知道我爸爸每天在工作中都在“嗨”。我发现是因为我爸爸得了癌症。那是一个可怕的一周。它开始于发现我爸爸背部的疼痛不仅仅是神经受压。最后诊断结果是淋巴瘤，一种我们那天学到要为之加油的特殊淋巴瘤，因为它是可以治愈的。这就是他们用的词。那时候，我甚至不知道癌症还能这么说。
But that whole week, my dad was convinced he had a different diagnosis, lung cancer. Even towards the end, when the doctors were pretty convinced the news was good, he insisted on it, which didn't make any sense. My father had quit smoking cigarettes way back in the '80s.
但那一整周，我爸爸坚信他得了另一种诊断，肺癌。即使在最后，当医生们确信消息是好的时候，他还是坚持这么认为，这完全说不通。我父亲早在80年代就戒烟了。
When we pressed him about it, that's when he told us about the pot. My dad's cancer and recovery was a pivotal time for our family. Painful secrets came out. Much was said that needed to be said. My dad got into a 12-step program. And he's been clean for almost 15 years.
当我们逼问他时，他才告诉我们关于大麻的事。我爸爸的癌症和康复是我们家庭的一个转折点。痛苦的秘密被揭露了。很多需要说的话被说了出来。我爸爸加入了12步康复计划。他已经清醒了近15年。
But then, here at the radio show, someone suggested doing a show called "I was so high," and I realized something. I really wanted us to do that show. I had a lot of questions for people who got high all day, questions about what they thought of themselves, what they thought of their families, what they were getting out of being high. I realized, in other words, I had a lot of questions for my dad.
但后来，在我们电台节目这里，有人建议做一个叫“我当时太嗨了”的节目，我意识到一件事。我真的很想让我们做那个节目。我对那些整天处于“嗨”状态的人有很多疑问，关于他们如何看待自己，他们如何看待家人，他们从“嗨”的状态中得到了什么。换句话说，我意识到，我对爸爸有很多疑问。
When did you use marijuana for the first time?
你第一次使用大麻是什么时候？
Uh, I don't know. You were about a year and a half old.
呃，我不记得了。你当时大约一岁半。
First, of course, I wanted the details. When did it start? When did it get serious? And for my dad, it started in the '60s. A friend rolled a joint at a party. It was fun. It became something he did socially, getting high with friends, listening to Jefferson Airplane on the brand new FM station in town.
首先，当然，我想要细节。什么时候开始的？什么时候变得严重的？对于我爸爸来说，是在60年代开始的。一个朋友在聚会上卷了一根烟。很有趣。它变成了一种社交活动，和朋友一起“嗨”，听着城里新开的调频电台上的Jefferson Airplane乐队。
And this part I knew. I remember joints passed around when my parents' friends came over, rolling papers on the end table next to the couch. One afternoon, I answered the door and found a friend of my dad's, turtleneck, sunglasses, what I remember as a Burt Reynolds mustache. He handed me a dime-bag and said, this is for your father.
这一部分我是知道的。我记得当父母的朋友过来时，烟卷在传递，沙发旁边的茶几上有卷烟纸。一天下午，我开了门，发现我爸爸的一个朋友，高领毛衣，太阳镜，我记忆中像是伯特·雷诺兹（Burt Reynolds）式的胡子。他递给我一个小袋子，说，这是给你父亲的。
My dad doesn't remember the first time he smoked weed at work. But it was probably around the time I was leaving middle school and entering high school. By the time I left for college, it had gone far beyond a thing he did at nights with friends to a thing he did routinely, during the day, while he'd walk the several blocks to a meeting with one of his firm's largest clients.
我爸爸不记得他在工作中第一次抽大麻是什么时候。但那可能是在我离开初中进入高中左右的时候。到我上大学时，它已经远远超过了他晚上和朋友一起做的事情，变成了一种例行的事，在白天，当他走过几个街区去与他公司最大的客户之一开会时。
I knew where every alleyway between our office on Seventh Street and Procter, on the other corner of downtown.
我知道市中心第七街我们办公室和Procter之间的每一条小巷。
And you're talking about a meeting with Procter & Gamble--
你说的是与宝洁公司（Procter & Gamble）的会议——
Yeah.
是的。
--one of the largest companies in the world. That was one of clients. If there's any company less associated with habitual work-time pot use, it has to Procter & Gamble.
——世界上最大公司之一。那是客户之一。如果说有什么公司与职场习惯性抽大麻关联度最低，那一定是宝洁公司。
Right.
对。
So, when you were making these presentations, you don't think that they knew that you were high at the time? That you'd stopped in at an alley on the way over and smoked a joint?
所以，当你在做这些演示时，你不认为他们知道你当时处于“嗨”的状态吗？你曾在去途中的小巷里停下来抽了一根烟？
No. I was putting something over on the straight world.
不。我在把某种东西瞒过现实世界。
Like, I'm not really part of your world. I'm just visiting here for a little bit.
就像，我并不是真正属于你们的世界。我只是在这里逗留一小会儿。
I think that was something that was very, very much a part of being stoned. Here I was, this guy in a business suit, tucking down a back alley and smoking a joint.
我认为那是非常非常处于“嗨”状态的一部分。我穿着西装，钻进后巷抽烟。
Another question I had for my dad, were there people for whom his drug use was not a secret? Other members of the Society of Secret Pot Smokers that he'd duck into that alley with? Was he regularly sharing joints with-- I don't know-- the Kinko's guy while they both waited on a large print order?
我对爸爸还有另一个问题，有没有人对他吸毒的事不是秘密的？还有没有别的他会溜进那条小巷的秘密大麻吸食者社团的成员？他是否经常与——我不知道——金考（Kinko's）的那个家伙分享烟卷，当他们都在等一份大打印订单时？
I could see a camaraderie developing between secret pot smokers, just like cigarette smokers at an office will go out and take smoke breaks together. But my dad says that, for him at least, it wasn't like that. Sure, he knew of other people at the agency who smoked pot. And yes, if you must know, they were mostly in the art department. But he mainly kept to himself.
我可以看到秘密大麻吸食者之间产生了友情，就像办公室里的香烟吸食者会一起出去抽烟休息一样。但我爸爸说，至少对他来说，并不是那样的。当然，他知道公司里其他人也吸大麻。是的，如果你一定要知道的话，他们大部分在美术部。但他基本上独来独往。
You increasing live in a secret world that you can't reveal to the people who don't share that world. And there are an increasingly limited number of people who share the world-- the more you use, the deeper you get into it, to the point where you're all alone in it. And you have to keep it a secret from everybody else. And you do really stupid things to keep it a secret, really stupid.
你越来越生活在一个你无法向不分享那个世界的人揭示的秘密世界里。分享这个世界的人数越来越有限——你用的越多，陷得越深，以至于你一个人在里面。你必须对所有人保密。为了保密，你会做非常愚蠢的事情，非常愚蠢。
What are you thinking of when you said "really stupid"?
当你说到“非常愚蠢”时，你在想什么？
Well, I remember one time, I went down, I'd stopped in Eton Park on the way back to the office. And I got out of the car. And I got stoned. I smoked a joint. And I came back, and I realized that I'd locked my keys in the car. And I couldn't-- you know, I was stoned. My judgment was shot. I didn't know what to do.
嗯，我记得有一次，我开车，回办公室的路上停在Eton公园。我下车，我吸了点。我抽了一根烟。我回来时，意识到我把钥匙锁在车里了。我不能——你知道，我“嗨”着呢。我的判断力没了。我不知道该怎么办。
So I went around. And I found a big rock. And I broke the little window in the rear. And I reached in and unlocked the door. And then, the back of the seat was full of glass. And I had to go down to Ace Auto Glass and had the glass replaced. And then, finally, I got to the office an hour and a half late for the meeting. And I made up some excuse. [LAUGHS]
所以我绕过去。我找了一块大石头。我把后车窗打破了。我伸手进去打开了门。然后，座椅后面全是玻璃。我不得不去Ace Auto Glass把玻璃换掉。然后，最终，我比会议迟到了一个半小时。我编了个借口。[笑声]
This image of my dad in his suit, early morning, rooting around in the underbrush for a rock to throw through his own car window, I found it so shocking. It is one solution to the problem at hand. But it's hard to imagine a person who wasn't high, weighing all the options and deciding, you know the think I need to do right now at 8:00 AM on a work day? Smash in my own car window.
我爸爸穿着西装，清晨，在灌木丛中找石头砸自己车窗的形象，我觉得太震惊了。这是解决当前问题的一种方案。但很难想象一个没有处于“嗨”状态的人，权衡所有方案后决定，你知道我在工作日的早上8点现在需要做的事吗？砸开我自己的车窗。
And I know, as rock bottom stories go, this is nothing special. In general, my dad's addiction story barely registers on the family dysfunction scale. But his marijuana use was starting to fray the edges of his life. He and his business partner, Dale, were having regular fights over my dad's inability to show up to meetings on time, or fill out his time sheets, or just get things done when he said he would.
我知道，作为人生低谷的故事，这没什么特别的。总的来说，我爸爸的成瘾故事在家庭功能障碍量表上几乎算不上什么。但他吸大麻开始磨损他生活的边缘。他和他的商业伙伴戴尔（Dale）经常因为我爸爸不能准时开会，或者填不好时间表，或者只是在他答应的时候完成事情而吵架。
At a certain point, my dad sold his stake in the business for a nice chunk of money. But then, he lost most of it on a string of failed business ventures. I remember my dad trying to explain a couple of them to me at the time. I was just out of college at this point. And I never really understood what the products actually were or how they were going to make any money.
到了一定时候，我爸爸卖掉了他的股份，换了一笔可观的钱。但后来，他在一连串失败的商业冒险中赔掉了大部分。我记得爸爸当时试图向我解释其中的几个。我当时刚大学毕业。我从来没有真正理解这些产品实际上是什么，或者它们怎么赚钱。
Only in retrospect did I realize, after the cancer and the secret came out, those business ideas, they made a lot more sense if you were stoned. All told, in today's dollars, my dad probably lost somewhere north of half a million. And this brings me to the most basic question I had for my dad, the question that lay underneath all the other ones.
只有回顾过去，在癌症和秘密被揭露后，我才意识到，那些商业想法，如果你处于“嗨”状态，它们似乎更有意义。总而言之，按照今天的货币计算，我爸爸可能赔了大约50万美元以上。这把我带到了我对爸爸最基本的问题，那个位于所有其他问题之下的问题。
Why do you think you were getting high every day at work?
你觉得你为什么在工作中每天都要“嗨”？
Uh, I think that I was getting high because I didn't really feel that marketing was a worthwhile thing to do.
呃，我觉得我“嗨”是因为我觉得市场营销并不是一件有价值的事情。
This is part of it for sure. Getting high allowed my dad to retreat from this reality that he didn't want to face, that he wasn't a hippie anymore but, in fact, a guy in a suit with a job in advertising.
这绝对是其中的一部分。处于“嗨”状态让我爸爸能够从他不想面对的现实中退缩，他不再是个嬉皮士，实际上，是个穿着西装在广告业工作的人。
But that answer, it didn't feel like the full truth to me. Because he wasn't just running from reality at work. He was running from it at home as well.
但那个回答，我觉得并不是完全的真相。因为他在工作中不仅仅是在逃避现实。他在家里也在逃避。
The one time in particular I remember was we were on vacation out in California. It was one of the times we went to California. We did a big road trip across the country. It was sort of crazy.
有一次我记忆犹新，我们在加州度假。那是我们去加州的几次之一。我们做了一次穿越全国的公路旅行。那真是有点疯狂。
And we'd found some unbelievably beautiful little swimming hole in northern California. And we'd set up a tent. And the weather was perfect. And we were all getting out. We'd put on our swimsuits. And we were all getting ready to get in. And we'd just been visiting your friends Gene and Jan in San Francisco. And they'd given you some--
我们在北加州发现了一个难以置信的美丽的小游泳池。我们搭了个帐篷。天气完美。我们都出去了。我们穿上了泳装。我们都准备进去。我们刚在旧金山拜访了你的朋友吉恩（Gene）和简（Jan）。他们给了你一些——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
They'd given you some Berkeley gold, as they called it.
他们给了你一些伯克利金（Berkeley gold），正如他们所称的。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I remember you rolling a joint and saying something like, but first, it's time for little Berkeley gold, or something like that. And I remember being really upset. And part of, I think, the reason that I was so upset is I remember thinking, what in the world? What more could you want?
我记得你卷了一根烟，说类似的话，但是先，是时候来点小伯克利金了，之类的。我记得当时非常沮丧。我想我如此沮丧的原因之一是，我记得当时在想，这世上还有什么？你还需要什么？
And there's sort of a feeling of, are we not enough? It seemed like, almost even at that time in your life, you were almost sort of running from something even in that moment or wanting to change the reality a little bit in that moment. Is it--
有一种感觉，是我们还不够吗？似乎，甚至在你生命中的那个时刻，你几乎在那种时刻也在逃避什么，或者想在那个时刻稍微改变一下现实。是吗——
I think I probably was.
我想我可能确实是。
What were you--? What didn't you have?
你什么——？你缺少什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't know what it was. I had a perfect life.
我不知道那是什么。我过着完美的生活。
I guess that's where I feel like I go back to it was feeling. Like, I find when I've used pot, the thing that it takes away is it takes away feeling.
我想这就是我觉得我回到它是一种感觉的地方。就像，我发现当我使用大麻时，它带走的东西是它带走了感觉。
Yep.
是的。
Feelings become less intense. And I feel like, for whatever reason, the feelings of oh my god, this is so perfect. I love my family so much. Or, oh my god, this should be so perfect, but I'm pissed off at my wife. Or, I'm let down by my children, or whatever it is that you were feeling. I sort of feel like that's the thing that links all of the pot use. Is that true? Or is that just my theory?
感觉变得没那么强烈了。我觉得，无论什么原因，哦天哪，这太完美了。我太爱我的家人了。或者，哦天哪，这本该如此完美，但我对妻子很生气。或者，我被孩子们失望了，或者无论你当时在感受什么。我有点觉得那是链接所有大麻使用的事情。那是真的吗？还是那只是我的理论？
Yeah, I think it's true. It's part of what you're running away from. The most important thing is that you're running away from something. You're running away from looking at the world as it really is. You push all of that direct experience of reality away. It's not a good way to live. It's just not a good way to live.
是啊，我认为那是真的。那是你在逃避的东西的一部分。最重要的是你在逃避什么。你在逃避看待世界本来的样子。你把所有对现实的直接体验都推开了。这不是一种好的生活方式。这绝不是一种好的生活方式。
Oddly, for my dad, it wasn't just the happy moments he regretted checking out for, but the sad ones as well. For example, when his mother died of cancer. My aunt had been telling my dad that their mother's condition was getting worse, worse than their mother was letting on.
奇怪的是，对于我爸爸来说，他后悔错过的不仅是快乐的时刻，还有悲伤的时刻。例如，当他的母亲死于癌症时。我的姨妈一直告诉我爸爸，他们母亲的情况正在恶化，比母亲透露的还要严重。
If my dad hadn't been high, he says, he wouldn't have ignored what my aunt was telling him. He would have spent more time with his mother, engaged more with her doctors.
如果我爸爸当时没有处于“嗨”状态，他说，他不会忽视我姨妈告诉他的事。他会花更多时间陪他的母亲，更多地与她的医生沟通。
I probably would have been in Cleveland with her when she had the operation that ended in her death.
我可能本来会在克利夫兰陪她做那场最终导致她死亡的手术。
Oh, I didn't know that she died during operation.
哦，我不知道她是死于手术期间。
Yes. She had bone cancer. And they were trying to break a connection to the pituitary gland or something like that that would reduce the pain. And she wound up hemorrhaging and died.
是的。她患有骨癌。他们试图切断与脑下垂体的联系之类的东西，以减轻疼痛。她最终大出血死了。
Mm. And you thought about going with her when she did that and you decided not to?
嗯。你当时想过在她做手术时陪着她，而你决定不去？
If it were to happen today, there's no question that I would have driven her up to Cleveland. That would've been the most natural thing in the world to do.
如果那发生在今天，毫无疑问我会开车送她去克利夫兰。那会是这世上最自然的事。
Instead, he says, he got high, pushed the feelings aside, and avoided the whole thing, which makes this last story I'll tell all the more amazing. Just last month, my 80-year-old Uncle Paul, my mom's brother, fell ill suddenly and ended up in the hospital, near death, with a breathing tube down his throat.
相反，他说，他“嗨”了，把情绪推到一边，回避了整件事，这使得我将要讲的这个最后一个故事更令人惊叹。就在上个月，我80岁的保罗舅舅，我妈妈的兄弟，突然病倒，住进了医院，濒临死亡，喉咙里插着呼吸管。
My parents got the call and were on a plane down to Florida where he lived the very next day. My uncle was a recluse. Except for occasional phone calls to his brothers and sisters, he interacted with almost no one. It was my parents and a neighbor that Paul barely knew confronting the sad end to his lonely life, Medicaid applications, power of attorney, hospice, finally, cremation.
我父母接到电话，第二天就飞往他居住的佛罗里达。我舅舅是个隐士。除了偶尔给兄弟姐妹打个电话，他几乎不与任何人接触。是我的父母和一个保罗几乎不认识的邻居在面对他孤独生活的悲伤结局，医疗补助申请、授权书、临终关怀，最后，火化。
And while my parents were down there going about all that, my dad did something that was, on the one hand, utterly ordinary, but that I found remarkable. He emailed us with regular, almost daily, updates, giving the details on Paul's changing condition, going through next steps. The emails were direct and honest, filled with love for Paul and sadness about his decline.
而在我父母在那里处理所有这些事情时，我爸爸做了一件，一方面，极其普通，但我发现值得注意的事情。他定期，几乎每天给我们发邮件，提供保罗情况变化的详细信息，进行下一步工作。邮件直接而诚实，充满了对保罗的爱和他衰退的悲伤。
And I would sit there and read them. And they felt miraculous. A daily email on a tough, hard-to-face topic from my dad, something he never could have done organizationally or emotionally when he was high.
我会坐在那里读它们。它们感觉像奇迹。一封关于我爸爸难以面对的艰难话题的日常邮件，当他处于“嗨”状态时，他永远无法在组织上或情感上做到这一点。
Like I said, as these stories go, ours wasn't that bad. My dad was a good dad. He read to us every night, took us on long hikes in search of snakes and salamanders to keep as pets. But his drug use did leave at least one lasting effect on me. I can't hear any story about a seemingly functional pot-head with anything but a skeptical ear.
就像我说的，作为这些故事，我们的并不算太坏。我爸爸是个好爸爸。他每晚给我们读书，带我们去长途远足寻找蛇和蝾螈作为宠物。但他吸毒确实给我留下了一个持久的影响。我对任何看似功能正常的大麻瘾君子的故事都抱着怀疑的态度。
From magazine features about rappers who are constantly high but still put out platinum records to casual asides about this friend I know who smokes weed all day but is a great husband and father, some part of me just can't buy it, can't help but think, there's more to that story. There's always something being run from. And there's always at least one person wondering, is that something me?
从关于那些总是“嗨”着却仍能发行白金唱片的说唱歌手的杂志专栏，到关于我认识的那个朋友整天抽大麻却是位好丈夫和好父亲的随意话语，我的一部分就是无法买账，不禁认为，故事背后还有更多。总有什么东西在被逃避。总有一个人在想，那个人是我吗？
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, Marc Maron, Wyatt Cenac and what do you say to Drew Carey when you are a contestant on The Price is Right and you're also high on mushrooms? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，马克·马龙，怀亚特·塞纳克，当你是《价格猜猜看》（The Price is Right）的参赛者，而且还吸了迷幻蘑菇时，你该对德鲁·凯里（Drew Carey）说什么？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life from Ira Glass. Each weekend our program, of course. We choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "I Was So High," stories about doing drugs, the people who do lots of drugs, and the rest of us who maybe do not do as many drugs.
这是来自艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）的《美国生活》。每个周末我们的节目，当然。我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“我当时太嗨了”，关于使用药物的故事，那些大量使用药物的人，以及我们这些可能没有使用那么多药物的人。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, You Were So High. So there are people who are not getting high every single day and organizing their whole lives around drugs. There are people in this world who get high, and have fun, and giggle with their friends.
我们到达了节目的第二幕——第二幕，你当时太嗨了。所以有些人并不是每天都在“嗨”，并没有围绕药物组织他们的全部生活。这世界上确实有人在“嗨”，玩得很开心，和朋友们傻笑。
Among other things, drugs can be enjoyable. And we asked you to send in your drug stories on our blog and Facebook and Twitter. You sent in 2,600. Elna Baker was one of three staffers here at This American Life who went through those emails. And she joins me in the studio now. Elna, what were most of those emails like?
除其他事项外，药物是可以令人愉快的。我们要求你们发送药物故事到我们的博客、Facebook和Twitter。你们发了2600条。埃尔纳·贝克（Elna Baker）是《美国生活》的三名工作人员之一，他们翻阅了这些电子邮件。她现在和我一起在录音室。埃尔纳，大多数邮件是什么样的？
I would say about half of them are people just doing really dumb stuff while they're high, like this.
我想大约一半是人们在“嗨”的状态下做真正愚蠢的事情，就像这样。
I called my friend Shane. And when I got him, I was like, well, I think I might have done some mushrooms. He's like, where are you? I was like, I'm at the intersections of One Way and Do Not Enter. He's like, look at other signs.
我给我的朋友肖恩（Shane）打了电话。当我接到他时，我说，好吧，我想我可能用了些蘑菇。他说，你在哪儿？我说，我在单行道和禁止进入的交叉路口。他说，看其他的路标。
I thought I picked up the bud. And instead, I picked up goose poop and took a nice big hit of it.
我以为我捡到了花蕾。但相反，我捡起了鹅粪，狠狠地吸了一口。
I would stop and write little poems. One just said, what if you were a cat and all you could say was meow? All you would have to talk about is meow.
我会停下来写些小诗。其中一句说，如果你是一只猫，而你唯一能说的就是“喵”会怎么样？你唯一能讨论的就是“喵”。
So one of the reasons why we asked listeners for their drug stories is because we thought we'd get a lot of funny stories. Were they funny?
所以我们要听众提供药物故事的原因之一是因为我们认为我们会得到很多有趣的故事。它们有趣吗？
They were OK. They weren't that funny. And I feel mean saying that because so many people actually put the effort to write us stories in. And we read 2,600 of these emails. But they don't stand up unless you either know the person or were there, or if you were on drugs at the time, it was funny to you.
还可以。没那么有趣。说实话我觉得很刻薄，因为很多人确实花了精力给我们写故事。我们读了这2600封邮件。但除非你认识那个人，或者当时在现场，或者如果你当时也处于“嗨”的状态，否则对你来说这很有趣，否则它们站不住脚。
It's like hearing people's dreams.
就像听人们做梦一样。
Yep.
是啊。
So it's like 2,600 emails, but they're not so funny.
所以是2600封邮件，但没那么有趣。
Mm-mm. There was a few or one liners that I remember, inside jokes.
嗯嗯。我记得有几个或几句俏皮话，内部笑话。
Like?
比如？
I'm loving that bunny. That was somebody--
我爱死那只兔子了。那是某个人——
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Exactly, people had their drug catch phrases that I kind of liked, that I want to use now.
没错，人们有他们药物的流行语，我有点喜欢，我现在想用。
[LAUGHS] OK.
[笑声] 好的。
But one was some little boy was on anesthesia. And he had this horrible surgery. And his parents were very worried. And they looked up at the TV screen. And there was Animal Planet. And he just looked up and was like, I'm loving that bunny.
但其中一个是一个小男孩在使用麻醉剂时。他做了一个可怕的手术。他的父母非常担心。他们抬头看向电视屏幕。那是动物星球频道。他只是抬头说，我爱死那只兔子了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It made me laugh.
这让我笑了。
But that's about as good as it gets.
但那就是最好的情况了。
Yeah, that's about as good as it gets.
是啊，那就是最好的情况了。
Any surprises?
有什么惊喜吗？
Yes. A lot of people, especially teenagers, will hit on their anesthesiologists while they're under the influence.
有。很多人，尤其是青少年，在受影响时会勾引他们的麻醉师。
So that's like a thing you know if you're an anesthesiologist?
所以如果你是麻醉师，那是你知道的事情？
And if you're hot, yeah. And then, oh, several people doing shrooms had a vision of a Native American guide appearing to them on the path in the distance--
如果你很火辣，是的。然后，哦，有几个人在使用迷幻蘑菇时，幻觉中有一个美洲原住民向导出现在远处的路上——
Oh my god.
天哪。
--and just gesturing for them to follow, which just seemed racist, right?
——只是向他们示意跟随，这看起来很种族歧视，对吧？
It does.
确实是。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
It's like a message from your unconscious. Hi, I've been meaning to tell you, by the way, you're a racist.
这就像来自你潜意识的信息。嗨，顺便说一下，我一直想告诉你，你是个种族主义者。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
OK, good. Now you know it. But you did get one email that turns out to be a really funny story. Who is this?
好的，很好。现在你知道了。但你确实收到了一封邮件，结果是一个非常有趣的故事。这是谁？
Josh Androsky. So Josh, one day, goes out with his friends. They're drinking. They end up doing mushrooms. And then they go to be part of the studio audience of The Price is Right.
乔什·安德罗斯基（Josh Androsky）。所以乔什，有一天，和朋友出去。他们在喝酒。他们最终用了蘑菇。然后他们去参加《价格猜猜看》的现场录制。
Already without mushrooms it would have been crazy.
即使没有蘑菇，那也会很疯狂。
[CHEERING CROWD]
[欢呼声]
Here it comes!
来了！
Because, literally, old people are dancing with children in the aisles. This one old lady starts booty dancing on Drew Carey. There were just dollar signs and flashing lights. I mean, everybody's going crazy. We were, demonstrably, the least high-looking people there.
因为，真的，老年人在过道里和孩子们跳舞。一位老太太开始对着德鲁·凯里（Drew Carey）跳翘臀舞。到处都是美元符号和闪烁的灯光。我的意思是，每个人都疯了。我们明显是那里看起来最不“嗨”的人。
Now it is the most exciting hour of fantastic prizes, the fabulous 60-minute Price is Right!
现在是激动人心的精彩奖品小时，精彩的60分钟《价格猜猜看》！
[CHEERING CROWD]
[欢呼声]
It was so, just, awe-inspiring, seeing all the colored lights that I didn't actually hear, "Come on down."
那真是，太令人敬畏了，看着所有彩色的灯光，我实际上没有听到，“快下来”。
Joshua Androsky, come on down!
乔舒亚·安德罗斯基，快下来！
All of a sudden, I looked on the stage. And there was this PA who was holding up a sign with my full name on it, which was really, really scary. Because, in my head, it wasn't like, "Joshua Androsky, come on down."
突然，我看向舞台。有个制片助理举着写有我全名的牌子，这真的很可怕。因为，在我的脑海里，那不像，“乔舒亚·安德罗斯基，快下来”。
In my head, that sign was, "Joshua Androsky, we know that you're here." There was that light bulb that went off in my brain that was like, oh my god. I'm going to play The Price is Right now.
在我的脑海里，那个牌子是，“乔舒亚·安德罗斯基，我们知道你在这儿”。我脑海里亮起的那盏灯像是，哦天哪。我现在要去参加《价格猜猜看》了。
[CHEERING CROWD]
[欢呼声]
Let's get the show started with the first prize up for bid today on The Price is Right.
让我们用今天《价格猜猜看》的第一个奖品开始这个节目。
Excellent idea, Drew. We're going to start off with a new home theater system!
好主意，德鲁。我们要以一套新的家庭影院系统开始！
I was the first person to bid on the first prize on contestants' row.
我是第一个在参赛者行列里竞标第一个奖品的人。
It goes to whoever bids closest to the actual retail price without going over. Big papa, we're going to start with you.
谁的出价最接近实际零售价且不超过它，谁就获胜。大老爹，我们要从你开始。
And I'm an idiot. And I bid $1 every time. [LAUGHS]
我是个白痴。我每次都出价1美元。[笑声]
For that, I'm going to bid $1.
为此，我出价1美元。
$1! All right, big papa bids $1. Big papa hat, Dolly Parton shirt, bid $1.
1美元！好的，大老爹出价1美元。大老爹帽子，多莉·帕顿（Dolly Parton）衬衫，出价1美元。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm a mystery, dude.
我就是个谜，伙计。
That's--
那是——
That's an enigma. Get used to it.
那是个谜题。习惯就好。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Miraculously, one of the $1 bids worked. And I got up. And then, Drew Carey was like, hey! OK, cool. What do you do?
奇迹般地，其中一个1美元的出价成功了。我上去了。然后，德鲁·凯里像是，嘿！好的，酷。你是做什么的？
But that's when all the mushrooms hit me at once. And I just looked at him and I said, I'm a skateboard rabbi.
但就在那时，所有的蘑菇一下子冲到了我的脑子里。我看着他说，我是个滑板拉比。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
A skateboard rabbi. Uh--
滑板拉比。呃——
Drew Carey turns to me and goes, how do you incorporate skateboards into Judaism? I was like, well, Drew Carey, we go to local high schools and attempt to turn religious extremism into religious "X-tremism!"
德鲁·凯里转向我，说，你是怎么把滑板融入犹太教的？我说，嗯，德鲁·凯里，我们去当地的高中，试图把宗教极端主义变成宗教“极限主义”！
Unfortunately, they cut it out of the show. I get it. [LAUGHS] I did! But if you watch the video, the studio audience is going crazy. And Drew Carey looks right at the camera and goes--
不幸的是，他们把它剪掉了。我懂。[笑声] 我懂！但如果你看视频，现场观众都疯了。德鲁·凯里直视镜头说——
He really is a skateboard rabbi!
他真的是个滑板拉比！
Josh Androsky, he went home from The Price is Right with a diamond ring.
乔什·安德罗斯基，他从《价格猜猜看》带回了一枚钻戒。
Act Three, Bottom of the Eighth. We now turn to this story from Wyatt Cenac, recorded live on stage at Seth Herzog's SWEET at the Slipper Room in New York City.
第三幕，八局下半。我们现在转向怀亚特·塞纳克的故事，在纽约市Slipper Room的Seth Herzog's SWEET现场录制。
A lot of people, they assume I smoke a lot of pot--
很多人，他们以为我抽很多大麻——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--because I talk kind of slow and I look like in high school jazz teacher.
——因为我说话有点慢，我看起来像个高中爵士乐老师。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I don't really smoke weed. I don't smoke it that much, because I don't get high smoking weed. It doesn't affect me. It doesn't affect me. I've only once gotten high from pot. And that was one time I ate a pot brownie.
我不怎么抽大麻。我不常抽，因为抽大麻我不会“嗨”。它对我没影响。它对我没影响。我只有一次因为大麻“嗨”了。那是唯一一次我吃了一块大麻布朗尼。
Ooh.
噢。
Yeah, that's right. That's the right response. [LAUGHS]
是啊，那是正确的反应。[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I ate a pot brownie. I was about eight years ago. I was living in California at the time. And it was Memorial Day weekend. And I was with three of my friends. And we decided to go to a Dodgers game. And so, it was me, my friend Ben, my friend Steve, and Steve's brother, Sweet Dave.
我吃了块大麻布朗尼。大概八年前了。我当时住在加州。那是阵亡将士纪念日周末。我和三个朋友在一起。我们决定去看一场道奇队的比赛。所以，是我，我朋友本（Ben），我朋友史蒂夫（Steve），还有史蒂夫的兄弟，甜心戴夫（Sweet Dave）。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You could try to call him Dave if you want to. But he won't answer to anything but Sweet Dave. Like, if a tiger was about to attack and you were like, Dave, look out! Sweet Dave would die.
如果你想叫他戴夫，你可以试试。但他除了“甜心戴夫”之外谁也不理。比如，如果老虎要攻击，而你叫“戴夫，小心！”，甜心戴夫会死的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And so it's the four of us. We're in the parking lot at Dodger Stadium. We're tailgating. And one of my friends is like, hey, I got some pot brownies. And I'm going to let you guess which friend of mine said that.
所以我们四个。我们在道奇体育场的停车场。我们在搞车尾派对。我其中一个朋友像是，嘿，我有些大麻布朗尼。我要让你们猜猜我哪个朋友说的。
Sweet Dave?
甜心戴夫？
Wrong. It was Ben.
错了。是本。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But Sweet Dave was like, sweet!
但甜心戴夫像是，甜心！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And so, Ben had four pieces of pot brownies for the four of us. And it seems like, oh yeah, four and four. Here's a little twist. At this point in my life, at 30 years old, I had never had pot before. And also at that point in my life, I had no job. I was living off my credit cards, which my credit cards didn't really appreciate.
所以，本给我们四个人每人准备了一块大麻布朗尼。看起来，哦，是的，四块和四个人。这里有个小转折。在我生命的那个时候，30岁，我从来没碰过大麻。而且在那时候，我没有工作。我靠信用卡生活，信用卡不太喜欢这样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was about to get evicted. And I was five months behind on my car note. And so I looked at my friends. And I was like, eh, I don't really have anything to live for. Let's go. And I ate the brownie. And then, we went into the game. And we sat down. And we're all sitting in Dodger Stadium.
我就要被驱逐了。我的车贷也拖欠了五个月。所以我看着朋友们。我想，呃，我真的没什么好活着的了。来吧。我吃了布朗尼。然后，我们进场了。我们坐下。我们都坐在道奇体育场里。
And I can see that it's starting to hit my friends. Like, they're all starting to look around and get a little giggly. And it's hitting them. And my friend Ben looks at me. And he's like, you feel it yet? And I was like, nah. But I do got to take a piss.
我能看到它开始对我朋友产生影响了。他们都开始环顾四周，有点傻笑。它生效了。我朋友本看着我。他像是，你感觉到了吗？我说，还没。但我得去撒泡尿。
So I get up and I go to the bathroom. And I come back. And Steve is in it hard. I can see. He's just sitting straight up. And his arms are crossed. And he's just watching the field, not the game, the field.
所以我起身去洗手间。我回来时，史蒂夫已经完全陷进去了。我能看出来。他直挺挺地坐着。交叉双臂。他只是在盯着场地看，不是比赛，是场地。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And Ben looks at me. He's like, you feel it yet? And I was like, nah. But I really got to take a piss.
本看着我。他像是，你感觉到了吗？我说，还没。但我真的得去撒泡尿。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I did that eight more times. [LAUGHS]
我又做了八次。[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And my phone rang. I answered the phone. But no words would come out. I couldn't say anything. And I could hear my friend Laura on the other end. And she's saying hello.
我的电话响了。我接了电话。但一个字也说不出来。我什么也说不出。我能听到我朋友劳拉（Laura）在电话那一头。她说你好。
Then, I'm trying so hard. I'm just like, say something. Just talk. Talk damn it! And finally, I am like, (UNUSUAL ACCENT) I am so [BLEEP] high. This is terrible.
然后，我非常努力。我只是想，说点什么。说话。该死的说话！最后，我像是，（异常口音）我太[哔]嗨了。这太糟糕了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I did it in that voice. And I have never done that voice before in my life. I don't know where that voice came from. But I heard myself use that voice. And in my mind, I went, oh [BLEEP]. I just gave myself Down Syndrome.
我用了那个声音。我生命中从没用过那个声音。我不知道那个声音从哪来的。但我听到自己用了那个声音。在我的脑海里，我心想，哦[哔]。我刚才给了自己唐氏综合症。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
(NORMAL VOICE) Now let me just say, I know what Down Syndrome is. I know that Down Syndrome is something that you're born with when you are born with an extra chromosome. I know all that information. I knew that information then. But something about eating this brownie made me think that somehow I had grown an extra chromosome and I now had adult-onset Down Syndrome.
（正常声音）现在让我说清楚，我知道什么是唐氏综合症。我知道唐氏综合症是你出生时多了一条染色体。我都知道所有这些信息。我当时知道那些信息。但吃这块布朗尼的某些东西让我觉得，不知怎么地我多长了一条染色体，现在我得了成人发作的唐氏综合症。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And for people who have Down Syndrome, it's something they grow up with. And they grow up and they have healthy and happy lives. I just got it.
对于患有唐氏综合症的人来说，那是他们从小就有的。他们长大了，有健康快乐的生活。我只是刚得了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I start freaking out. I'm just like, I'm going to have to explain this to people. And I start panicking. And I just start freaking out, freaking out to the point where I start weeping in the middle of Dodger Stadium.
我开始抓狂。我像是，我得向别人解释这件事。我开始恐慌。我开始抓狂，抓狂到我在道奇体育场中间哭泣。
And then, I start laughing. And then, I start weeping again. And then, a bunch of cops start walking towards me. And something in my brain just clicks on. It's like, Wyatt, you have to keep it together right now. I was like, (UNUSUAL ACCENT) yes. Keep it together.
然后，我开始大笑。然后，我又开始哭泣。然后，一群警察开始走向我。我脑子里有什么东西突然点击了一下。就像，怀亚特，你现在必须镇定。我说，（异常口音）是的。镇定。
(NORMAL VOICE) Yeah, Wyatt, there are cops right there. They cannot know you are high. (UNUSUAL ACCENT) No, they cannot know I am high. (NORMAL VOICE) And now, my internal monologue has become my external monologue. And I start pointing at the cops.
（正常声音）是啊，怀亚特，警察就在那儿。他们不能知道你“嗨”了。（异常口音）不，他们不能知道我“嗨”了。（正常声音）现在，我的内心独白变成了外部独白。我开始指着警察。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I'm like, (UNUSUAL ACCENT) you cannot know I am high. I have to fool  you. I am fooling you.
我说，（异常口音）你不能知道我“嗨”了。我得愚弄你。我在愚弄你。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
(NORMAL VOICE) We thought maybe it's time we should leave Dodger Stadium. I'm not sure exactly how far into the game we were. I know it was past the first inning. We might not have made it to the third inning.
（正常声音）我们想也许是时候离开道奇体育场了。我不确定我们看了多久。我知道过了第一局。我们可能没坚持到第三局。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But we leave. And we get back to Steve's place. Ben immediately leaves, goes home, sees his roommate who's like, hey, what's up? And he goes, I think I killed Wyatt.
但我们离开了。我们回到史蒂夫家。本立刻走了，回家，看到他的室友像是，嘿，怎么了？他说，我想我杀了怀亚特。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Steve decides to park himself on the couch and watch TV, not TV shows, just a blank TV.
史蒂夫决定瘫在沙发上看电视，不是电视节目，只是空白电视。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Sweet Dave went to a cookout.
甜心戴夫去参加了一个烹饪聚会。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He was fine.
他没事。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wyatt Cenac. You can catch him every Monday night hosting a show called Night Train at Little Field in Brooklyn, New York.
怀亚特·塞纳克。你可以在周一晚上在纽约布鲁克林的Little Field主持一个叫“Night Train”的节目见到他。
Act Four, Straight Man. So, Marc Maron is a comedian who, for a long time, very aggressively did smoke pot, every day. He also did coke, and LSD, and mushrooms. He says that, for a while, he did so many drugs that he was hearing voices.
第四幕，直男。所以，马克·马龙是一位喜剧演员，很长一段时间里，非常有侵略性地抽大麻，每天。他也吸可卡因，LSD和蘑菇。他说，有一段时间，他吸了太多的毒品，以至于他听到了声音。
He first tried to get sober in 1988. He has now been continuously sober for over 15 years. He's best known these days for his podcast, WTF, which is basically the New York Times of comedy podcasts. It's like the comedy podcast of record. Every comedian goes on to talk to Marc. He also has a TV series on IFC.
他1988年第一次尝试戒酒。他现在已经连续清醒了超过15年。他最近最出名的是他的播客《WTF》，基本上是喜剧播客界的《纽约时报》。这就像喜剧播客的纪录。每个喜剧演员都会去和马克谈话。他还在IFC有一个电视系列剧。
We reached out to him because he's been on both sides of the line, right? He's been a daily drug user. And he has been sober. And we thought that he would just have some perspective on what each side thinks of the other.
我们找到了他，因为他站在界线的两边，对吧？他是个每天的药物使用者。他也是个清醒的人。我们认为他对两边怎么看对方会有一些视角。
So we're doing this episode of our show this week with a lot of drug stories. And you seemed like the perfect person to ask this question of, because I know that you're someone who loves a funny story when you hear it.
所以我们本周做这集节目，带有很多药物故事。你看起来是问这个问题的完美人选，因为我知道你是个听到有趣故事就喜欢的人。
But you're also somebody who has seen what addiction can do to people. So, one of the questions I wanted to ask you is, given how drugs kill people and how dangerous they are, is it OK to laugh at these stories?
但你也是一个看到成瘾能对人造成什么样伤害的人。所以，我想问你的问题之一是，考虑到药物如何杀死人以及它们有多危险，笑这些故事是可以的吗？
Of course it is.
当然可以。
Why?
为什么？
Because they're funny. Most drug stories are stories about people who are out of control in some way and get into horrendously risky or embarrassing situations. And--
因为它们很有趣。大多数药物故事是关于那些在某种程度上失去控制，陷入极其危险或尴尬境地的人的故事。而且——
I know. But isn't it glorifying a thing that shouldn't be glorified? You know what I mean? Have people told you stories that you enjoyed-- like even on your podcast-- have people told you stories that are funny stories, but there's a little part of you that's in recovery that cringes a little bit?
我知道。但这难道不是在美化不该被美化的事情吗？你知道我的意思吗？人们告诉过你你喜欢的故事——就像在你的播客上——人们告诉过你有趣的故事，但你内心处于康复状态的一小部分会有点退缩吗？
Oh, yeah. But I think that the other side of glorification is-- I would say that it's as much of a red flag or a warning sign as it is a glorification. You're going to laugh on either side of that.
哦，是的。但我认为美化的另一面是——我会说这既是危险信号或警告标志，也是一种美化。你会在这两边都笑。
It's like, oh my god! That guy almost died. I am so glad that I do not live that life. But you can also see that as, like, there is a strange courage to it. And I think that mythology is wearing away.
就像，哦天哪！那个家伙差点死了。我很高兴我不过那种生活。但你也可以看出那就像，有一种奇怪的勇气在里面。而且我认为那种神话正在消退。
That mythology being?
那种神话是？
That there is a courage to the drug adventurer.
即药物冒险者有一种勇气。
Right.
对。
I think that was something that the '60s was sort of built on. And I think that it was something that creativity and art was sort of built on, that there was struggle, and torment, and alcohol, and drugs, that people wrestled this amazing--
我认为那是60年代建立起来的东西。我认为那是创造力和艺术建立起来的东西，即有挣扎，痛苦，酒精和毒品，人们与这个惊人的——
And that there was something to learn from drugs.
而且从药物中学到了什么。
I do think there's something to learn.
我确实认为有什么可以学习的。
You do?
真的吗？
Well, yeah, I did that big story on my '95 HBO half hour about going to a Jerry Garcia concert and being on mushrooms by myself. And I will stand by that story as being the primary thing that you learn on drugs.
嗯，是的，我在95年HBO半小时节目里讲过那个大故事，关于一个人去看杰瑞·加西亚（Jerry Garcia）演唱会，自己用蘑菇。我坚持那个故事，认为那是你在药物上学到的主要东西。
Wait, I don't know this story, I'm sorry to say. What happens? Not to make you do an entire bit here but, essentially, what happens?
等等，我不知道这个故事，很抱歉。发生了什么？不是让你现在表演一遍，但本质上，发生了什么？
Well, what happens is I'm going to see Jerry Garcia with my roommates. It was at the Orpheum, I believe, in Boston. And I'm in college. And I'd gotten my tickets from these two girls I didn't know that well. One of them was in my class.
嗯，发生的是我和室友去看杰瑞·加西亚。那是波士顿的Orpheum，我想。我还在上大学。我从两个我不怎么认识的女孩那里拿到了票。其中一个在我班里。
And my roommates had their tickets. And we're going to the concert. And we just eat a big bag of mushrooms. And we get to the concert. And they're going to sit somewhere else.
我室友有他们的票。我们要去演唱会。我们只是吃了一大包蘑菇。我们到了演唱会。他们要坐在其他地方。
So I'm all alone with these strange girls. And I'm beginning to trip on mushrooms. And it's not good. You just feel that weird kind of amp.
所以我和这些陌生的女孩独自一人。我开始因为蘑菇而产生幻觉。这不好。你只是感觉到那种奇怪的放大。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
You start getting that surge where you begin to trip on hallucinogens. And your head feels like it's about to pop off. And your perception is starting to change. And I'm starting to freak out a little bit. Because I don't know who I'm with.
你开始获得那种 surge，开始因为致幻剂而产生幻觉。你的头感觉要弹开了。你的感知开始改变。我开始有点抓狂。因为我不知道我和谁在一起。
My roommates are down somewhere else, sitting there. And I'm looking at these girls. And their faces are a little too large now. And everything's getting a little sweaty. And I'm starting to panic. And I'm thinking, like, OK. I could always go to the emergency room if I freak out. I could just go to the emergency room.
我室友在下面某个地方，坐在那儿。我看着这些女孩。她们的脸现在有点太大了。一切都变得有点出汗。我开始恐慌。我想，好的。如果我抓狂，我总能去急诊室。我只是去急诊室。
And I think that the women I'm sitting with, who don't really know me, are sensing that I'm starting to panic. And they're like, do you want some gum? And I'm like, oh god, that would be so good. Gum would just be the right thing right now, like everything is when you're tripping.
我想和我坐在一起的女士们，并不真正认识我，感觉到我开始恐慌了。她们像是，你要口香糖吗？我像是，哦天哪，那太好了。口香糖现在正是正确的东西，就像你“嗨”的时候一切都是一样。
Oh, of course, gum! And they give me a piece of gum. And it's Freshen-Up. And I didn't really register it until I put it in my mouth. So this gum explodes. And I think--
哦，当然，口香糖！她们给了我一片口香糖。是Freshen-Up。在我放进嘴里之前我没真正注册它。所以口香糖爆炸了。我想——
[LAUGHS] The gum with the squirty inside, right?
[笑声] 那种里面有液体的口香糖，对吧？
Yeah, right. And I think I'm bleeding. And I spit the gum out. And I'm just panicking. It's just awful. And then, the lights go down.
对，没错。我想我在流血。我把口香糖吐了出来。我只是在恐慌。这太可怕了。然后，灯光暗了下来。
And then, Jerry comes out. And he looks fat. And I'm hyper-sensitive on the mushrooms. And I think I'm reading things. And I'm feeling things. I'm an empath. And I realize Jerry's in trouble. He's overweight.
然后，杰瑞出来了。他看起来很胖。我对蘑菇超敏感。我想我在读东西。我在感受东西。我是一个同理心者。我意识到杰瑞有麻烦了。他超重了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
His voice doesn't sound good. So now, I'm freaking out on Jerry, who is really supposed to be the ultimate guide through this experience, you know?
他的声音听起来不好。所以现在，我在杰瑞身上抓狂，他本该是这次体验的终极向导，你知道吗？
Right, like calmest calm-inducing person.
对，就像最能诱发冷静的人。
Right. He's the mythological Drug Buddha. And if I'm getting a bad vibe from Jerry, I got nowhere to go. And then, I notice there's one of those guys sitting in front of me who has clearly been to too many Dead shows and done so much acid that he operates at a different frequency than other people. He's kind of jerky. And he's got a very graceful but odd way of just holding his body. You see them at these type of events. [LAUGHS]
对。他是神话中的药物佛陀。如果我从杰瑞那里得到了糟糕的氛围，我无处可去。然后，我注意到我前面坐着一个家伙，他显然去了太多的Dead演唱会，吸了太多的酸，以至于他的频率与别人不同。他有点抽动。他有一种非常优雅但奇怪的方式来控制他的身体。你在这些类型的活动中看到他们。[笑声]
And I'm thinking to myself, he'll help me out. This guy will throw me a line. So I'm trying to socialize with this guy. And I tap him on the shoulder. And I go, hey, you know, pretty soon one day, Jerry's going to come out and him and his guitar are just going to be fused. They're going to be, like, one thing.
我在对自己说，他会帮我的。这个家伙会给我一条线索。所以我试图和这个家伙社交。我拍拍他的肩膀。我说，嘿，你知道，很快有一天，杰瑞会出来，他和他的吉他会融合。他们会成为，像，一件事。
And this guy just cocks around with such precise hallucinogenic focus. And he looks me right in the eye. And he goes, (UNUSUAL ACCENT) just hang on, man! Just hang on.
这个家伙以如此精确的幻觉焦点转过身。他直视我的眼睛。他说，（异常口音）只要坚持住，伙计！只要坚持住。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he turns around. And I'm like, that's it. I will do that. I will hang on.
他转过身。我心想，就是这样。我会做到的。我会坚持住。
Wait, and is that the insight one can have on drugs? Is just hang on?
等等，这就是药物上能有的洞察力吗？只是坚持住？
Yeah, a lot of times, if you just hang on, it'll pass.
是的，很多时候，如果你只是坚持住，它就会过去。
When you were smoking every day, did you feel superior to people who weren't doing drugs?
当你每天抽烟时，你觉得自己比不吸毒的人优越吗？
I felt like I had a secret. I don't know of that's superior. But I felt like, oh man, I'm so glad I'm seeing this like I'm seeing it. So I guess there is a slight superiority in that, that I'm not on this hamster wheel, man. You know, I'm just walking down the street. And I'm really seeing what the sunlight is doing.
我觉得我有一个秘密。我不知道那是否优越。但我感到，哦天哪，我很高兴我看到的是我所看到的。所以我猜这有一点点优越感，即我不在这个仓鼠轮上，伙计。你知道，我只是走在街上。我真的在看阳光在做什么。
It's sort of double-edged though. Because the squares are the people that try to function in the world-- like, weird moment back when I was doing a lot of coke. And I think it speaks to your point. I had this woman that I dated in college. She came out to visit me in LA.
不过这是双刃剑。因为方正的人（Squares）是那些试图在世界上运作的人——就像我吸很多可卡因时那个奇怪的时刻。我想这印证了你的观点。我在大学时有个约会的女人。她来LA看我。
And I was living at this creepy old mansion behind The Comedy Store that Mitzi Shore owned. And we were just up there at all hours, doing drugs, and staying up all night, and playing guitar, and talking about whatever for hours. So this woman comes to visit me. And it's like 3:00 in the morning. And she's just a regular girl who works for-- now, she works in health administration.
我住在喜剧商店后面那个Mitzi Shore拥有的阴森恐怖的老宅子里。我们只是在那儿全天候，用药，整夜不睡，弹吉他，谈论whatever几个小时。所以这个女人来看我。那是凌晨3点。她只是一个普通女孩，为——现在，她在卫生管理部门工作。
But so, she comes out to visit me. And we're up in the middle of the night. And I'm just reveling in it, like, this is amazing, man! Nobody lives like this! We're living! And then, she leaves completely discombobulated and visibly upset for things I couldn't quite understand.
但所以，她来看我。我们半夜在上面。我只是沉浸其中，像是，这太棒了，伙计！没有人这样生活！我们活着！然后，她完全混乱，明显不安地离开，原因我无法完全理解。
And she sends me a handwritten letter, because that's what we did then, basically explaining to me-- she's like, you know when you stood up and just celebrated the fact that nobody lives like we do? And she wrote, I don't know if you know this, but nobody would really want to live like that.
她给我寄了一封手写信，因为那时我们就是那样做的，基本上向我解释——她说，你知道当你站起来庆祝没有人像我们这样生活时？她写道，我不知道你是否知道这个，但没有人会真正想要那样生活。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, what do you think you're doing over there staying up all night, doing blow, playing guitar, and talking about nothing for hours to the point where none of you can function in the real world at all? It's like, no! We're the ones who are winning!
就像，你以为你在那儿整夜不睡，吸可卡因，弹吉他，谈论空无一人几个小时，以至于你们没人能在现实世界中运作，你在做什么？就像，不！我们才是赢家！
So that superiority is very shortsighted. And each side feels superior to the other. But no, I do think that their side sort of wins.
所以那种优越感是非常短视的。每一边都觉得比另一边优越。但没有，我确实认为他们那一边赢了。
Their side being the straight people?
他们那一边是正直的人？
Well, being the people that can function in this society that we're supposed to sort of function in.
嗯，是那些能在我们本该运作的这个社会中运作的人。
Well, I feel like you get so quickly, in this kind of discussion, to there are just two different ways to drink or do drugs. And there's all the people who can't control it. And they end up alcoholics and addicts. And then, there's all the people who can control it. They can do it occasionally, and they're fine. And it's just--
嗯，我觉得在这种讨论中，你很快就会得出，仅仅有两种不同的喝酒或用药方式。有所有那些无法控制它的人。他们最终成了酒鬼和瘾君子。然后，有所有那些可以控制它的人。他们可以偶尔做，他们很好。而且它只是——
Those horrible people.
那些可怕的人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Those horrible people that can have a couple of drinks. Or even worse, the people like, yeah, I smoke a couple of cigarettes, maybe, on the weekend. You horrible person! Where's your sense of commitment?
他申请了特别许可参加听证会，因为他有一些想对证人托马斯·哈里根（Thomas Harrigan）说的话。哈里根是负责执行联邦毒品法的机构DEA的二把手。这两个人互不相让。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I mean, don't you want to invest your life in this project? OK.
我的意思是，你不想把你的生活投资在这个项目里吗？好的。
I want to play you a clip of you. This is you performing in 1998. I think you're just off drugs at this point. But maybe not.
我想给你放一段你的片段。这是你1998年的表演。我想你这时刚停药。但也可能没有。
In all honesty, I feel bad for people who have never been addicted to anything. Because they're the real losers.
老实说，我为那些从来没有对任何事情上瘾的人感到难过。因为他们是真正的失败者。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You want to know why? Because they just don't know what it's like to really want something-- and get it again, and again, and again--
你想知道为什么吗？因为他们根本不知道真正想要某种东西是什么感觉——然后一次又一次地得到它——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--until their sick and have to stop.
——直到他们生病，不得不停止。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's passion.
那是激情。
Do you still feel that way?
你还那么觉得吗？
Yeah. [LAUGHS] I feel that way as a survivor. And it's very hard for me to say-- like, I don't regret the times I did drugs. I don't regret the times that I almost died or was in horrible situations. I don't regret wasting, possibly, years of my life. Because I can't live like that. I can't live in those regrets.
是啊。[笑声] 我作为一个幸存者那么觉得。很难让我说——我不后悔用药的时候。我不后悔我差点死去或者陷入可怕境地的时候。我不后悔可能浪费我几年生命的时候。因为我不能那样生活。我不能生活在那些遗憾中。
But some of those times were great times. Some of those times were hilarious times. I don't regret all those times. I mean, am I happy that it didn't drag me down the hole? And hurt a lot of other people? And make me sick in a way that I could not get better or even die? I'm happy about that. But I am also thrilled that I had some of the experiences I did. And that's the two sides of it.
但其中一些时光是美好的时光。其中一些时光是搞笑的时光。我不后悔所有那些时光。我的意思是，我很高兴它没把我拖进坑里吗？伤害其他人吗？让我生病以至于我无法变好甚至死去吗？我对此很高兴。但我同样激动我拥有了一些经历。这就是它的两面性。
Marc Maron. The second season of his TV show on IFC starts May 8.
马克·马龙。他在IFC的电视节目第二季5月8日开始。
Act Five, "DEA Agent Takes a Hit." So this is a moment when everything seems in flux in how our country sees and deals with drugs, particularly marijuana. Case in point, the past few months in Congress, the House Government Oversight Committee has been holding a series of hearings called "Mixed Signals, the Administration's Stance on Marijuana."
第五幕，缉毒局特工吸了一口。所以这是一个当我们的国家看待和处理毒品，特别是大麻的方式似乎一切都在变动时的时刻。举个例子，过去几个月在国会，众议院政府监督委员会举行了一系列名为“混合信号，政府对大麻的态度”的听证会。
These are the Committee's first hearings on pot in a decade. And they're holding them now, in large part, because so many states-- 20 states plus Washington, DC-- now allow some form of legal marijuana, which of course is in direct conflict with federal drug law. And one of the interesting things about these hearings is that two congressmen who think that our marijuana policies are totally out of whack, they think that pot should not be illegal under federal law-- have been using these hearings as an opportunity to, basically, lay into narcs, just to chew them out.
这些是委员会十年来对大麻的首次听证会。他们现在举行是因为许多州——20个州加上华盛顿特区——现在允许某种形式的合法大麻，这当然与联邦毒品法直接冲突。关于这些听证会的一个有趣的事情是，两名认为我们的大麻政策完全搞错了的国会议员，他们认为大麻在联邦法律下不应该非法——一直在利用这些听证会作为机会，基本上，责骂缉毒警察，只是狠狠地教训他们一顿。
It's kind of incredible. You almost never hear people on two sides of this issue talk to each other this directly, this fiercely, in public. One side, OK, sees pot smoking as normal, everyday, no biggie. What's the fuss? The other side sees the everyday-ness of pot as the problem, as a menace. Brian Reed tells about one of these congressional face-offs.
这有点不可思议。你几乎从没听过这个问题两边的人如此直接、如此激烈地在公开场合交谈。一边，OK，认为抽大麻是正常的，每天，没什么大不了的。有什么好大惊小怪的？另一边认为大麻的日常性就是问题，作为一种威胁。布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）讲述了其中一次国会交锋。
I'm going to play you my favorite tape from these hearings. It's of one of the congressmen, Steve Cohen from Memphis in an Oversight Committee hearing on March 4. Cohen isn't even on the Oversight Committee, by the way.
我要放我最喜欢的听证会录音给你听。这是3月4日在监督委员会听证会上，来自孟菲斯的史蒂夫·科恩（Steve Cohen）国会议员的录音。顺便说一下，科恩甚至不在监督委员会里。
He asked for special permission to take part in the hearing, because he had some things he wanted to say to the witness, Thomas Harrigan. Harrigan is second in charge of the agency tasked with enforcing federal drug laws, the DEA. The two men do not see eye-to-eye.
他申请了特别许可参加听证会，因为他有些话想对证人托马斯·哈里根说。哈里根是负责执行联邦禁毒法律的机构——美国缉毒局的二把手。这两个人意见不合。
Mr. Harrigan, you've been in this business now for close to 30 years? 1987, you started with the DEA. How have your views changed on marijuana in those 30 years?
哈里根先生，你在这一行已经接近30年了？1987年，你从DEA开始。这30年来你对大麻的看法有什么改变？
To be quite honest with you, sir, very little.
老实说，先生，几乎没有。
I was afraid of that.
我怕就是这样。
I see the devastation--
我看到了破坏——
That's enough. The fact that it's changed very little says a lot about--
够了。事实证明它几乎没改变，说明了——
Do you want me to respond to your question, sir?
你想让我回答你的问题吗，先生？
No, sir.
不，先生。
Because I would be happy to.
因为我会很乐意。
I know you would. We have limited time. The fact that it's changed very little shows that you haven't kept up with society. You haven't kept up with science. And it's part of the problem--
我知道你会。我们时间有限。事实证明它几乎没改变，表明你还没跟上社会。你没跟上科学。这是问题的一部分——
Science and medical I do keep up, sir.
科学和医学我确实跟上了，先生。
All right. You mentioned in your statement that, quote, "It insults our common values." I want you to read me what you said.
好的。你在声明中提到，引用，“这侮辱了我们的共同价值观”。我要你读给我听你说的话。
Yes, sir. I believe this is the section you're referring to. "We also know that marijuana destroys lives and families, undermines our economy, and insults our common values."
是的，先生。我相信这就是你指的那部分。“我们也知道大麻摧毁了生命和家庭，破坏了我们的经济，侮辱了我们的共同价值观。”
What are the common values it insults?
它侮辱了什么共同价值观？
For me, sir?
对我来说，先生？
No, for--
不，对——
I will tell you. I will tell you if you let me.
如果你让我说，我会告诉你的。我会告诉你的。
You said, we know. You're speaking as clairvoyant voice of America. What are our common values?
你说，我们知道。你说话就像美国的千里眼。什么是我们的共同价值观？
Well, I would venture to guess all of law enforcement, just about every single parent out there as well.
嗯，我敢猜测所有执法部门，几乎每一位父母也是。
Every single parent?
每一位父母？
Yes, every single parent. It's based on, again, medical, sir, and scientific fact, not public opinion. OK, I am not the medical expert, as I said before. Everything that I do is based on my 30 plus years of law enforcement.
是的，每一位父母。它是基于，再次重申，医学，先生，和科学事实，而不是公众舆论。好的，我不是医学专家，如我之前所说。我所做的一切都是基于我30多年来的执法经验。
Let me stop you for a minute. You said, it insults our common values. What is the value it insults?
让我打断你一下。你说，这侮辱了我们的共同价值观。它侮辱了什么价值观？
What is the value it insults?
它侮辱了什么价值观？
Yeah, you said, this--
对，你说，这个——
Do we have all--? I could easily go on and on.
我们有所有——？我可以轻易地继续说下去。
You haven't started yet.
你还没开始呢。
Well, you continue to interrupt me. I would be happy to address your question.
嗯，你一直打断我。我很乐意回答你的问题。
Answer my question, sir.
回答我的问题，先生。
Yes, you know what? From a bare minimum, as a parent, as a former educator, as a law enforcement official for all these years, I have seen the devastation that marijuana has caused not only on individuals, on families and communities.
是的，你知道吗？从最起码的角度来看，作为一名家长，作为一名前教育工作者，作为一名执法官员，我多年来已经看到了大麻不仅对个人，对家庭和社区造成的破坏。
What's our common value, though? You still haven't stated the common value. And the fact is 55% of Americans are in favor of decriminalization or legalization. I got to imagine that some of them are parents.
不过我们的共同价值观是什么？你还是没陈述共同价值观。事实是55%的美国人赞成去刑事化或合法化。我得想象他们中有些是父母。
Your statement that all parents are against this is ludicrous. Want do you think? People that are in favor of decriminalization or a change in policy--
你说的所有父母都反对这个，是荒谬的。你怎么想？那些赞成去刑事化或改变政策的人——
I didn't say, all.
我没说，所有。
--don't procreate?
——不生育？
I said, most parents--
我说，大多数父母——
You said, all.
你说，所有。
--would be opposed to this.
——会反对这个。
And most is wrong too, 55% of America!
而且“大多数”也是错的，55%的美国！
Are they all parents?
他们都是父母吗？
I don't think that the polls went into that. But I suspect a whole bunch of them were. It's not--
我不认为民调深入到了这一点。但我怀疑他们中有很多是。它不是——
This went on for more than five minutes.
这持续了超过五分钟。
Let's get beyond Richard Nixon.
让我们超越理查德·尼克松。
I call the DEA to see if Thomas Harrigan wanted to come on the radio and have a chance to actually respond, since Cohen barely let him get a word in edgewise. But the DEA spokesperson said Harrigan was busy preparing for another hearing this week, so he couldn't do it.
我给DEA打电话，看托马斯·哈里根是否想来电台有机会真正回应，因为科恩几乎没让他说上一句完整的话。但DEA发言人说哈里根正忙着准备本周的另一场听证会，所以他做不了。
As for Congressman Cohen, one of his biggest beefs with the country's drug policy is the fact that marijuana is classified as a Schedule 1 drug. That means, in the eyes of the federal government , marijuana has a high potential for abuse and no accepted medical use.
至于科恩议员，他对比国家毒品政策最大的不满之一是大麻被归类为一级毒品。这意味着，在联邦政府眼中，大麻具有很高的滥用潜力和没有被接受的医疗用途。
Heroin, LSD, peyote, these are all Schedule 1. Cocaine and meth, on the other hand, are Schedule 2, a less serious designation. So under federal law, marijuana is considered the most dangerous type of drug, more dangerous than cocaine and meth. In Cohen's words, that's poppycock. He says, marijuana is the least dangerous of these drugs and most people know it including, apparently, President Obama.
海洛因，LSD，仙人球毒碱，这些都是一级。另一方面，可卡因和冰毒是二级，一个没那么严重的指称。所以根据联邦法律，大麻被认为是最高风险的毒品，比可卡因和冰毒更危险。用科恩的话说，那是胡说八道。他说，大麻是这些毒品里风险最小的，大多数人都知道，包括，显然，奥巴马总统。
In a New Yorker profile earlier this year, Obama said, quote, "As has been well-documented, I smoked pot as a kid. And I view it as a bad habit and a vice, not very different from the cigarettes that I smoked as a young person up through a big chunk of my adult life. I don't think it is more dangerous than alcohol."
在今年早些时候《纽约客》的一篇专栏中，奥巴马说，引用，“如已有详细记录，我小时候抽过大麻。我把它视为一种坏习惯和恶习，与我年轻时一直抽到成年后很大一部分时间的香烟没什么不同。我不认为它比酒精更危险。”
In fact, Obama said, quote, "In terms of its impact on the individual consumer, he believes pot is less dangerous than alcohol," which just shows how confused we are as a country right now when it comes to what we're supposed to be doing about marijuana. You've got the president of the United States saying something like that about pot while, at the same time, he's the boss of an entire bureaucracy with thousands of people whose job is to think the opposite.
事实上，奥巴马说，引用，“就其对个人消费者的影响而言，他认为大麻不如酒精危险，”这恰恰显示了我们作为一个国家在处理大麻问题上有多么困惑。总统先生说过那样的话，与此同时，他却是一整个机构的领导，那里有成千上万的人，他们的工作就是认为相反的事情。
Brian Reed is one of the producers of our show.
布莱恩·里德是我们节目的制作人之一。
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike, our senior producers Julie Snyder, production help from Alison Davis.
嗯，我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔和我本人制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike），我们的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），来自艾莉森·戴维斯（Alison Davis）的制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Julie Beer and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。艾丽斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运行我们的网站。来自朱莉·比尔（Julie Beer）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）的研究帮助。来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. And thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, whenever I get on the back of his motorcycle with him, he never lets me wear a helmet.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，每当我坐上他的摩托车后座时，他从不让我戴头盔。
Just hang on, man. Just hang on.
只要坚持住，伙计。只要坚持住。
And I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。